[Music]
what do all action anime have in common
is it the powers yes but there's another
thing that they all have and most fans
look forward to and that's the rage
moments those moments where the
characters lose all their patience and
just snap and Unleash the Beast Within
them these scenes Run Deep in anime and
here from GIC going insane to Ichigo
releasing his inner Hollow I present to
you the top 20 best rage moments of all
time starting with blade of the
Guardians darar is one of the three
major characters in Blade of the
Guardians and with his skills in using
swords he's a formidable opponent
through and through laying eyes on the
seven head of His companion La Mo dalar
could no longer hold himself back and
was intoxicated with rage drawing his
sword dalar was ready to bathe in the
blood of his enemies with no mercy at
all he portrayed his Spirit as a warrior
and as a loyal friend ready to defend
those important to him without batting
an eyelid what made this moment worthy
of the first one on our list was the
animation the choreography was clean and
I even felt like I was angry for a
moment seeing just how well executed it
really
was next up we have Black Clover arar
versus
[Music]
ladros now this was the scene that made
us appreciate just how strong of an
individual arstar really is and the
first time we've seen him go all out
with his anti-magic and demon powers
ladros was confident and even attempted
to absorb arar's anti-magic sword when
all seemed lost in one of the most epic
moments of Black Clover arar entered his
anti-magic demon form and then we we all
knew where their entire budget was
thrown to the animation quality was
totally different from the beginning
parts of the series The Way arar
transformed the way he Blitz ladros at
the end especially the impact frames
when arar emerged from the Flames was
just epic although we did want arar to
end ladros which he didn't it meant the
ending of that moment still kept the
black clover charm this was one of the
few rage moments we'll ever get to see
in Black Clover and it's safe to say it
didn't
disappoint like
with another demonic transformation in
the list we have sarap of the end you
turns into a
demon after seeing all his friends
including shinoa suffer at the hands of
his enemies you couldn't hold back his
emotions and started screaming his lungs
out now this is what we expected to
happen to ASA where the MC just loses
control and gives into his Primal anger
and rage you was reborn into a monster
and even even if Mika was there he just
straight up destroyed everything in his
path with one simple move his rage
caused him to transform in a horrific
and immensely painful way which made the
scene even more amazing this was a true
rage moment where even if it didn't have
a million dooll budget animation the
impact was just as effective the black
ooze and his one giant Wing were perfect
in terms of character design not only
that this was a foreshadowing of what
was about to come and the bigger Horrors
that awaited the
characters
[Music]
next on the list we have a daily life of
the immortal King wangling shows his
true
power being a selfless and understanding
person wangling never wanted any enemies
but alas being The Reincarnation of the
immortal Emperor isn't easy after seeing
Sun wrong Soul perish in the hand of
xang wangling snapped the first reaction
of wangling was shock then Despair and
then the rage for the first time in so
long wangling was swallowed with rage
that even though froggy 2 stopped time
to prevent his Rampage wangling broke
through his spell just to get back at
Sun rong's murderer one thing you
shouldn't do in a cultivation anime is
to enrage the overpowered MC we also got
to see the true power of gender equality
the fight was one-sided and he wouldn't
even stop if it wasn't for a vision he
had with sun wrong what made this rage
moment so good was that it showed one
Ling still had his Humanity deep inside
of him including his ability to feel
anger he was so angry that even when
literal space froze it still couldn't
stop him the fight scene itself was
worth the watch with the beautiful
effects of their attacks being the
Highlight this goes to show that people
should stop sleeping on Chinese anime
and just give it a
go moving up on the list is Demon
Slayer now you wouldn't expect danir to
have a rage moment because of his nature
of being a good person but when he does
he goes all out and makes sure that any
demon he comes across is turned into
dust which is exactly what happened to
guaro after one of the best animated
fight scenes in the entire history of
anime takes place Dano gets his chance
to finally cut off guano's head while
zenitsu and inos take care of DHI in
sink this was a pure rage moment defined
by strength and sheer will even though
tanjiro took a sickle to the mouth he
still charged in which has got to hurt
the way Dano's eyes turned white the
manifestation of his Demon Slayer Mark
and his hair resembling a blazing flame
was breathtaking to watch viewers got
goosebumps as the slicing sound effects
at the very end made it all so
satisfying this was the beginning of
Dano's growth as a sun breather and how
he would become the foundation of the
Demon Slayer corpse
survival with another brutal showdown in
our top 20 we have Tokyo Ghoul Ken gaki
versus
Jason the fight in Tokyo Ghoul between
Ken kaneki and Jason is a significant
and brutal Showdown that occurs during
the series it's a pivotal point in
kaneki's Metamorphosis and progress as a
character the mood is tense with an
overpowering sense of hopelessness prior
to their fight giki endures weeks of
horrendous torture from Jason to the
point that giki's hair turns white after
accepting his inner gold giki goes into
rage mode and he might have thought
Jason broken and bent but he proved that
he was just as terrifying as the
strongest ghouls there are fans love
seeing Jason take a beating and on top
of it all giki made Jason count backward
and even ate him at the end which goes
to show how twisted giki suddenly became
from a shy human boy to a merciless half
go giki was smiling throughout the
entire Beatdown it was one of the best
scenes in Tokyo Gold and by far a
legendary moment in all of
anime
speaking of Legendary Moments next up is
fairy tale when natu transforms into
end as natu discovers his true identity
and relationship with end the
experiences a surge of betrayal rage and
determination Natsu's visual transition
into end is breathtaking his appearance
changes dramatically with scales horns
and demonic features all enveloped in an
ear Globe this buildup creates a lot of
excitement and sets the stage for a
spectacular transition the way the
visuals contrasted also emphasized How
Deep nsu's Emotions were I personally
loved seeing Natsu's wrath as at first
fairy tale was like Black Clover where
almost no one got killed even though
fairy tale isn't the strongest when it
comes to storytelling and animation the
buildup the transition the emotions and
Natsu's character development were all
perfectly harmonious it gave fans one
lasting fiery
impression
with iconic show after iconic show we
have another one from one piece when
Luffy punched a Celestial
[Music]
Dragon we all know who Straw Hat Luffy
is and we all know he delivered one of
the most satisfying punches in all of
anime as St taros celebrated his actions
the captain of the straw hats could no
longer contain himself the punch was
thrown so hard the Luffy momentarily
sent St charos back into the manga panel
before crashing into the seats behind
him even though the scene was a bit
funny it still showed Luffy's
convictions throughout the series we've
seen Luffy's undying dedication to his
companions and how sometimes he doesn't
realize some importunate issues going on
in the world or maybe he just stays
silent but his silent rage and his I
don't care what happens next attitude
made him look so badass at this moment
the moment may not have had crazy
animation or choreography but we
actually got to see Luffy go into full
rage mode after some time While others
reacted like it was the end of the world
for the straw hats it was just another
day with
Luffy next up is probably a show you
haven't heard of or have watched It's
sukimi Makoto snaps against
shom after seeing the memories of shon
through a misted gate marcoo learns what
had truly happened to his friends the
tragedy and death of his friends were no
accident but planned realizing what had
happened marcoo tracks down Shion to
enact his revenge it's not every day you
see an innocent character snap but man
maroto really created a Vibe of his own
I thought the show was just a happy
Slice of Life fantasy anime but it
proved me wrong with this scene alone if
you thought dairo was nice then Maro was
an angel so that's why it's so
surprising that when he's consumed with
rage even he could do what Asar couldn't
as he listened to her scream he casually
walked up to her and Mur mercilessly
stabbed her in the throat during this
time maroto had no intention of
regretting his choice after killing
Shion without an ounce of hesitation
Maro just contemplated the feeling of
having to kill someone the moment was
just scary as all it took was one clean
strike and everything had
ended moving on from maro's brutal
murder we have haime noo damura versus
hawk t
du to Hawk's Brash personality his
pre-fight trash talk and slapping
takamura's coach right in front of him
damura was dumbfounded and enraged
during their fight as damura was losing
Consciousness he snaps remembering it
was his opponent's fault that his coach
bled during the press conference this
was the moment where even if he was
about to go unconscious sheer will and
anger kept his body going the animation
was insane and everyone expected Daka
MAA to have a comeback but not as
beastly as this one this moment was an
exciting and emotionally packed
encounter that demonstrated the physical
and mental demands of professional
boxing as well as the dedication of the
people involved even when he was pushed
back to a corner dakam mura became a
monster and beat Hawk at the
end entering our top 10 in this list is
jiujitsu Kaizen when Yugi decided to
kill
mahito much like the others this is one
of those rare moments when the
particularly bright MC just enters rage
mode decides to stop playing and
releases all of their blood lust because
mahito was so twisted like a menace he
disrespected Yuji so much by turning gin
into a Transfiguration in front of him
worst of all when Yuji asked sukuna to
help him the king of curses just laughed
with mahito because of this Yuji just
broke down and he uttered the coldest
I'll kill you line in the series The
Animation to visualize yuji's rage was
insane you could feel the tension he was
bringing this moment is essential not
just for its impact on the plot but also
for Yuji ador's character growth and
development this was the moment everyone
knew that jiujitsu Kaizen wasn't kidding
around and gay was following hajim
isayama's footsteps Yuji proceeded to
give mahito the beating of a lifetime
and even though he managed to escape it
was then and there that he realized
there was some who could end his
life coming up is probably one of the
most iconic rage scenes in all of anime
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood Roy
Mustang takes on
[Music]
Envy this moment is always on lists like
this and rightfully so overcome by a
deep seething rage Roy was relentless
with his attacks and brought down Divine
punishment on envy each time Roy snapped
his fingers he burned Envy repeatedly
until he was nothing but Ash and burnt
flesh each attack was filled with his
anger and thirst for Revenge which was
why it was so satisfying to watch Roy's
wrath emotionally connects with the
audience viewers have grown to love Roy
as a character who represents loyalty
Justice and Devotion to his teammates
seeing him Focus his rage on a ferocious
battle against Envy was a once- in
a-lifetime moment for us to see his
character grow his usual calm and
strategic approach is replaced by a
Madman willing to do anything to avenge
his Fallen Friend the animation voice
acting and impact was undoubtedly
topnotch blitzing in at number eight is
Attack on Titan Levi defeats the Beast
[Applause]
Titan after Irwin's Godlike spee that
made each one of us feel like we were a
part of the scouts Levi who went into
demon mode after seeing every one of his
comrades die at the hand of the Beast
Titan proceeds to give us one of the
best one-sided fights in the series he
wasted no time and as Humanity's
strongest Soldier he rushed the Beast
Titan and brought it down in an instant
Levi even did one of the coldest poses
when he brought Zeke out and proceeded
to shove a sword inside his mouth the
moment was intense the way wit Studio
animated Levi's attacks was insane
especially when he sliced through the
Beast Titan's arm levite definitely had
a few rage scenes but this one was by
far the best in terms of emotional
impact and the anticlimactic ending it
had he proved that even if you're taller
than a house when you got a short angry
guy after you There Is No
[Applause]
Escape the next entry might be
unexpected for some individuals because
we have Gintama gintoki versus
jirocho
we all know that Gintama is a wacky
anime but for some who only see this
series as a joke it can be equally
dramatic intense and relatable if it
needs to be gintoki and jiro's conflict
stems from their own histories and
objectives gintoki threw out his funny
and laid-back personality and replaced
it with pure blood lust after he saw ad
do lifeless geroo was responsible for
all of this and he really regretted it
even though gintoki had a wooden sword
he was able to overpower jro show even
when it was broken the studio went all
out making it clear to us just how
powerful each of gintoki strikes were it
wasn't just anger gintoki was feeling
guilt and sadness as well which drove
him to become insane this moment proved
that Gintama wasn't all just fun in
games it could be serious as well giving
us another rage moment to
[Music]
remember if you asked your dad you'd
probably say this entry was one of the
most memorable moments in Dragon Ball
Goku rages after the friezer kills
Krillin in front of
[Music]
him this occurs during the Dragon Ball Z
series climactic fight on the Planet
Namek bruised and battered from a long
fight Goku stood in shock as to what
just happened he just witnessed the
death of his best friend Krillin at the
hands of his enemy Frieza seeing his
friend blow up in midair made something
deep inside Goku's snap the animation
might be old but it's no doubt worthy of
being top six after reaching his conic
form Goku proceeds to fight Frieza
pushing himself to the Limit the way
Goku just started screaming out of anger
and grief became a staple of the series
especially when he's transforming into
new forms and the moment Krillin just
exploded into Oblivion was just shocking
to see with an entry from the so-called
big three of anime we have bleach where
Ichigo unleashes his inner
Hollow
orora being one of the strongest espart
in aizen's Army proves to be an opponent
Ichigo couldn't be using his own
strength as hope seems to have
disappeared orime makes a desperate cry
for Ichigo begging him to help her and
by doing so ichigo's lifeless body
transforms into something sinister a
holic unlike any other Ichigo looks so
ruthless that it made all Kiora look
like the hero from Ichigo breaking the
ground behind him without even caring
for arime the one he was going to save
to him stepping on kora's head it was a
battle of Epic Proportions this hono
form was the acclamation of ichigo's
pent up anger and it did its job showing
us what would happen if you got on his
bad side the moment was amazing due to
its meticulous buildup stunning visuals
emotional resonance and the embodiment
of ichigo's character development and
ideals it's a pivotal moment that
showcases his growth as a hero with an
innate demon and leaves a lasting impact
on fans of the
series
moving in at number four we have the
moment when Naruto succumbed to his pure
hatred against
[Music]
pain with his teacher's death the
destruction of his village and Hinata's
unconscious body lying Motionless in
front of him Naruto's sanity was driven
to the edge in this moment of weakness
the nin Tales took over Naruto's body
using his rage although the fight did
have some weird and inconsistent
animation the way narut negated and
overpowered every attack pain threw at
him was just badass to watch the entire
fight reshaped the landscaped into a
desolate and Barren Wasteland the build
up towards Naruto's transformation the
animation and writing along with him
finally succumbing to his emotions was
Flawless at first we all thought Naruto
was going to pack up pain with sage mode
but it was even better seeing him go all
out Naruto was running at pain like a
madman hitting him with rubble until
only his head was the only thing out of
the ground better yet he even got a
second transformation looking scarier
than before as bones started coming out
from his body we got to see how
ferocious the QB really is and it didn't
disappoint when talking about rage
moments this one always has to be on the
list Mob psycho mobs 100% Rage Against
goyama
after witnessing his brother getting
beaten up by Guam mob immediately steps
in to save ritsu during his first
attempt Guama caught him off guard and
he was able to overwhelm mob using his
teley kinetic Helix mob's rage reached a
level he was so desperately avoiding
mob's emotions had hit 100% goyama stood
no chance at all and was being thrown
left and right goyama was at a
disadvantage to the point where mob just
grabbed his face and they just broke the
sound barrier the choreography of the
animation was one of its biggest
highlights making it more satisfying to
see mob teach goyama a lesson the
animation wasn't a downer either because
when it comes to rage moments you could
always count on Mob psycho to do the job
the vibrant colors the dynamic animation
and creative visual effects create an
intense and captivating spectacle that
draws viewers in mob's rage demonstrates
that even the most reserved and gentle
individuals have the potential for
Incredible strength when their emotions
are pushed to the Limit
coming in hot at number two we have
another underrated rage moment hiakim
Maru after Mio's
death what would you do if the only
person who ever showed you kindness was
killed right in front of you well as
hiakim Maru stood there listening to
Mio's faint voice as she sang in her
final moments something inside the young
man snapped asakim Maru screamed in
agony from the rage he felt no one could
have predicted what was about to happen
next instead of crying his eyes out
hiakim Maru instead went on a killing
spree stabbing and slicing his opponents
as he was Unstoppable there weren't any
special abilities no powerups no holding
back hiakim Maru was just going all out
making the ground turn red with his
opponent's blood this scene is brutal as
the audience Witnesses hiakim maru's
rage and sorrow which is both satisfying
and heart trending it's a moment that
encapsulates the complexities of human
emotions elevating it Beyond a mere
battle scene
and at number one the most watched and
most legendary rage moment in all of
anime we have Hunter Hunter gone versus
[Music]
neito as we journey together with gone
freaks we think of him as a Carefree
happy go-lucky kid that only has two
dreams to find his missing father and to
become a world-renowned Hunter so in the
cha antar after gon confronts neito the
one responsible for his friend kite's
death we see gone for the first time
ever exploding with rage sacrificing
everything he has just to enact his
revenge instead of the normal sudden
power up gone offered his entire future
and his potential as a human to gain an
insane amount of power this is when you
know gon was willing to risk it all
because he forced his body to grow to
the age where he was able to defeat
neito there were no other emotions here
it was just pure rage his es were so
heavy that they sent neito flying the
visual effects were out of this world
and the emotions were just too real to
take
him
okay and there you have it the top 20
rage moments in anime although I'm
pretty sure I missed a lot of other
moments like this one so be sure to let
us know your favorite in the comment
section below I hope you enjoyed
watching this video don't forget to like
share and subscribe see see
you